uh i wanted to ask you guys both um
[Music]
i mean first of all our condolences goes
out to his family and friends that's
most important
um you know may he rest in paradise
second of all um i think for a black
community to see someone like that for
our younger generation and the kids that
look up to guys like all of us to see a
guy like virgil break the barrier to be
able to go from where he started to be
able to work for
you know louis vuitton and nike and all
these unbelievable
uh companies you know as a black man i
mean it just does so much for our youth
you know uh two kids that grew up in the
inner city and myself and a.d you know
you just don't
just don't know what it can do uh to the
younger generation you know and and
obviously you know a lot of people look
at us as inspiration but we know
statistics on guys getting to the nba is
very low
um but i think you know when you look at
you know designers and musicians and
artists and things of that nature you
know virgil his
his um his impact on
um you know not only kids that's going
on right now but just our generation my
generation 80s generation and so on and
so on uh just big time impact and um
you know what he brought to the table
his flair his style his swag
um you see
on the feet of uh of a lot of people you
know and uh and on the bodies of a lot
of people on that on the heads of a lot
of people you know wearing hats and
clothing and socks and shoes and things
of that nature so
you know god like that's legacy will
live on so
i'm just proud to be a part of that
legacy oh yeah for sure and piggyback on
that you know just being from chicago
um
you know how much he's done for his city
um how much we've
you know
all-star chicago me and him did a thing
together as well um
but like brown said just touching so
many lies especially the black community
of
you know
his art you
know it's probably one of the first
times we've seen something like that
that the black community just gravitated
to so quickly it's not just a blackened
everyone you know everyone gravitated to
i mean he's
you know the phenomenal talent in what
he did um and what he's done with with
his art and to do it throughout the
world with this with his clothing and um
you know like brown said you see it you
see it on everybody you know i wore a
whole louis vuitton collection to today
i'm saying
you know what i'm saying like it's just
um you know he just brought so much you
know positivity to the world man it just
sucks you know and to think about it
like saying that with javier balzman
like
you know these guys
able to it was so low-key and um you
know i didn't really know about it but
you could see it in his appearance you
know to change but you know to be able
to you know go through
you know what he was going through and
still try to work and put out you know
work for the community man it's it's
it's unreal you know and um to show the
type of guy he was so like he said maybe
rest in peace and
you know condolences to his family for
sure